[Musique]
nous avons trois types de ce type de
lac régulier dans le monde deux au
cameroun qui ont éclaté dans les années 80 et
ce lac le risque avec ce type de
lac est que nous avons une sursaturation de
gaz
dans l'eau et qu'il peut  déclencher
ce qu'on appelle une éruption limnique
[Musique]
et dans les années 80 au cameroun les lacs
ça a tué plus d'un
millier de personnes donc on ne veut pas que ça
arrive ici
[Musique]
ouais c'est vrai qu'on essaie de  transformer ces
menaces en opportunité, donc retirer
ce gaz
si c'est fait correctement peut aider à
réduire le risque d'éruption limbique et
bien sûr si en utilisant ce gaz nous pouvons
aussi aider le pays à se développer en
produisant par exemple de l'électricité alors nous
avons deux chances de  une menace
[Musique]
lorsque vous comparez les émissions pour les
émissions de carbone a, nous comparons le kivwat
par rapport à une centrale diesel,
gardez ce qui est comme trois fois moins
polluant par rapport à une
centrale électrique diesel conventionnelle et est cinq à
six fois moins polluant dans  termes d'
émission de carbone à une
centrale à tourbe traditionnelle ou conventionnelle, donc je
dirais que pendant que nous brûlons ce gaz ici,
même s'il s'agit d'une plante fertile, il est toujours
considéré comme une source d'énergie propre
[Musique]